yeah this is a highly distressing case
that unfolded in the Scottish borders in
February of this year and it centers
around someone who was referred to as a
man inside the court building here in
the last few minutes A Man known as
Andrew Miller
but he also refers to himself as Amy
George the court heard that he is in the
process of transitioning to a woman at
this stage now this is important because
in February of this year we have learned
that this person while identifying as
Amy George while dressed as a woman
lured a schoolgirl into his car in the
Scottish borders while she was walking
home one Sunday evening and
got into the car the girl thought that
it was a safe haven given this person
was dressed as a woman there were no
buses in the area her phone we heard in
the court was out of battery so she got
into that vehicle and it quickly uh
descended into one of the most uh
dangerous crimes that the courtroom has
heard in quite a while this girl who of
course her anonymity must be protected
through this so details we have to be
careful about what we can see she was
taken back to the property of Amy George
Andrew Miller
locked in the bedroom and repeatedly
sexually assaulted the court heard some
pretty distressing details that we
cannot report for legal reasons taste
and decency clearly being one of them
but we heard that this girl made a brave
attempt to flee the scene uh and was
successful in that attempt after a great
many hours Andrew Miller Amy George had
fallen asleep the girl escaped that room
and managed to phone 999 the police
clearly descended on that property
within minutes and she was saved the
court heard that police said
that her fear was palpable now the court
heard some details around the person
appearing in the dock via video link
today we understand that at the time
they were identifying as a woman but
when they appeared in the police station
they said it would be easier to identify
as a man their gender assigned at Birth
they are currently in the process we
understand of transitioning as well the
detail is still unfolding here the
hearing is continuing but this is pretty
distressing content emerging of a school
girl a young girl who was abducted from
a street lured into a vehicle and
repeatedly sexually assaulted at the
hands of a local businessman who was a
butcher
okay thanks Connor